taking photos at night on your phone
used to look terrible but if you
purchased a new smartphone recently you
may have noticed that your night photos
have improved ah much better you can
even take photos of stars i'm julian
chicachu reviews editor at wired and
i've been reviewing smartphones for over
five years how has smartphone
photography gone from this
to this beautiful photo
before we get into the technology behind
the new night modes let's first have a
little chat about bad photos take a look
at this photo here taken on an iphone 5
around 2014 a couple elements stand out
to me like that classic lens flare or
the blur no matter how nice or advanced
the camera is it's always going to need
a good source of light that's exposure
the amount of light that reaches your
camera sensor right now this lovely crew
has lit me really well let me show you
if they cut the lights
now i'm backlit and underexposed this is
the iphone 3g in low light and this is
the iphone 13 pro in low light let's get
the lights back on
part of the reason the iphone 3g looks
so underexposed is because it didn't
spend a lot of time taking the photo
that's shutter speed that's the length
of time the camera's little door is open
exposing light onto the camera sensor
one of the main reasons night mode on
your phone asks you to stay still is
because the longer you have the shutter
open the more light you can let in which
will produce a brighter photo but here's
the thing in night photos the seconds
it's asking you to wait it's actually
taking more and more photos to make a
composite with machine learning
algorithms so night mode is a part of
the field of computational photography
i'm going to call up ramesh raskar at
the mit photo lab to get into the
technical element of how it works
hi julian would you be able to tell me
what exactly is happening when you take
a night photo in a modern day smartphone
there are three elements
in any photography there's capture
there is process and then there's
display
and what we have seen over the last 10
years is there is amazing improvement in
all three areas so how is the software
actually changing what the photo will
look like you will hear all these terms
hdr hdr plus night mode smart hdr but
all of them are roughly doing the same
thing this key idea of so-called deep
fusion where you're fusing the photos by
using machine learning and computer
vision is really the breakthrough in
today's low-light photography could you
explain hdr so hdr traditionally high
dynamic range simply means whether it's
bright scene or a dark scene you can
capture that in a single photo a
smartphone it has seen you know millions
of photos of a sunset or a food or a
human face it has learned over time what
are the best ways to enhance such a
photo and how to either reduce the
graininess or how to make it look more
vibrant and choose the right saturation
choosing those parameters is basically
machine learning when it comes to
photography now let's take a look at
this machine learning in action by
comparing some photos the one on the
left is the iphone 3g so quite a long
time ago and the one on the right is the
iphone 12. what are your first thoughts
in what they're doing differently so you
can see that you know the previous
phones just gave you a photo from a
single instant the photo on the right is
actually not physically real in the
sense that there were different things
people were you know bubbling their
heads and the lights were flashing and
so the photo is actually composed by
multiple instances so when you try to
fuse this multiple photos the light in
one photo could be at one direction
light in the later photo could be in a
different direction and it's taking some
clever decisions to create an illusion
as if this photo was taken at a single
instant here you can also see the hdr
into effect where you know the audience
is completely dark in the iphone 3g
photo whereas you can actually see
everyone's heads in the other one you
know if an ai is learning how to color
correct a night scene based on what it
thinks it should be are we moving away
from photorealism julian i think
photorealism is dead
we should just bury it and it's all
about hallucination
the photo you get today has almost
nothing to do with you know what the
physics of the photo says it's all based
on what this companies are saying the
photo should look like so yeah i took
one of these with the pixel 6 and one of
these with the iphone 13 max pro what
happened there that would have caused
those colors to be very different
between the two photos these two
companies have decided to give you a
very different photo experience the
pixel might have taken 20 photos it's
also recognizing you know certain
features you know whether there's a sky
is it outdoor
is it what kind of white balance it has
there's some automatic beautification
also being applied so most of the photos
we see are hallucinations but not the
physical representation of uh the world
out there these companies are providing
us with ways to control some of that
like turn off that beautification
feature or maybe make it even stronger
um do you think that's sort of where the
compromise will sort of lie with the
people that do want to maybe tailor some
of their own shots to give them that
control and those options to tweak their
settings the innovations in all these
three areas have actually taken the
control away from us
but in reality it's not that difficult
for these companies to provide those
controls back to us they're just making
an assumption that most consumers would
like to just take a photo click a button
and get something they really would like
to see whether it matches the reality or
not i think the thing that we really
care about
is you know we go on a trip and you
reach paris and the eiffel tower is you
know in a haze and what you would like
to see is take a photo with your family
with eiffel tower in the back as if it's
a bright sunny day
right
and that's where
as a consumer you yourself are willing
to separate the physics the reality from
hallucination because if somebody can
paste just a bright
shine bright sunny photo
of eiffel tower behind your family
you'll be pretty happy about it so you
know we kind of focused on night
photography every time we look at the
nighttime photos those actually do seem
to be improving year over year but
broadly what would you say are some of
those challenges that are left for
photography in general when it comes to
smartphones in terms of night mode there
are lots of challenges right now i mean
if you want to do something that's high
speed uh you know it's very difficult to
capture that
at night time it's also difficult to
capture very good color in night time
because nighttime photos have when they
use burst mode the challenge with burst
mode is that every frame has a so-called
read noise so there's a cost you know a
camera pace every time it reads the
photos
but the other technique many companies
are using is just using lots of tiny
lenses now some phone companies have
five lenses and that's one trick to
capture just five times more light how
does that affect the rest of the phone's
capabilities what sort of can we expect
in the future photography or imaging
should give us superhuman powers you
know so we should be able to see through
fog we should be able to see through
rain you know we should be able to see
through see like a butterfly and see all
the spectrums not just the three colors
i think the notion that we should just
see what we are seemingly experiencing
is not enough on displays but i would
like to see a beautiful viewfinder you
know if i'm in paris and as i'm moving
my viewfinder it should tell me hey if i
take a picture of that eiffel tower it's
very jaded a lot of people already taken
a photo but if you if you kind of keep
rolling and this tiny statue actually
not enough people have taken the photo
of this so i think we're going to see
this very interesting progress in
capture
processing and display and i'm very
excited about what photography of
tomorrow will look like
[Music]
i'm going to show you some of my
favorite features with the iphone 13 pro
and the google pixel 6. we're doing low
light photography so let's cut the
lights
let's open up the camera and see what
happens
with night mode you can see that i'm
already in a pretty dark area so night
mode has been triggered here once you
tap it you can actually control the
length of the exposure so if you think
that you might need a longer shot
sometimes that might produce a brighter
image if i tap on the background it'll
expose for the background and it will
also change the focus there so you can
actually slide it up and down to change
the brightness or the shadows in the
shot those are just a couple of features
in the camera app themselves all right
let's bring the lights back on
so we have to talk about tripods tripods
are an easy way to up your photo game
especially at night of course you know a
large problem of taking photos at night
is the handshake of when you're taking a
photo
once more can we cut the lights
can i get a volunteer
so now i'm gonna first take a photo
without a tripod and see how it reacts
then
so you can just basically switch over to
the night sight mode
and tap the photo
but now
if i switch over to a tripod
it's going to be much more stable
and if i tap the button it knows that
it's on a tripod and you can see it is
taking a lot longer to take the photo
it's taking multiple multiple images of
different exposures
shooting handheld is a problem because
the shutter speed is trying to take in
as much light as possible and that means
your hands are shaking and that's
influencing the shot that's what makes
it impossible taking photos of stars
without a tripod certain phones like the
pixel 6 let you take photos of the star
with a certain astrophotography mode and
essentially it's doing what night mode
is doing but for a much longer period of
time like two three sometimes even five
minutes and what it really needs is the
phone to be on a tripod if you're
curious about what some of our favorite
phones are for taking photos or maybe
just looking at other camera gear that
might help you take some of these better
photos well we have guides on wired.com
and as ramesh said it's going to be
really interesting to see how our
cameras improve in the future whether
they'll completely decide on their own
exactly what photo you should take or if
you'll have any control left
photorealism is dead
that's dark jesus
i hope this video helped you understand
a little bit more about knight
photography and i hope you continue
going out there taking lots and lots of
photos
[Music]